even guys in like you know close
quarters I'm like yo man what's your
spirit yeah nobody's nobody saying no hi
my name is phil and i have male factor
infertility so back in 2012 my wife Alex
and I just started this journey on okay
we're gonna start a family and we
thought oh gosh this is just gonna be
easy and are we just prepared for a baby
in nine months and the reality was that
journey that I thought was typical was
for us everything but typical it was me
later that year getting checked and
realizing I had male factor infertility
and so my sperm development wasn't
working it wasn't happening the way it
should happen and biologically for
whatever reason or another I had slow
swimmers I had weak swimmers I had
swimmers that didn't know where they
were going and for me what it did was it
started to lower day by day by day my
own intrinsic value of myself I'm ready
to talk to these guys about what their
scenario is and see what we can find out
about them and what their journey might
be
hey man I'm Zack what's up man I'm
Brendon hi I'm Tristan what's up what's
wrong how are you um good kinda nervous
okay don't be nervous commoners so like
what are what's like a common like sperm
count for men and is it is a differ
ending on age group an age range yeah so
actually male infertility in general is
actually on the decrease in fact there's
a handful of studies right now that have
been produced in the past six months
that are actually saying that years like
let's say 30 40 50 years ago like a
normal sperm count for a man would be a
hundred million okay
right now we're sitting at least in the
Western culture somewhere around 50
million so it's half right in the last
30 40 50 years one of the biggest
studies was a Hebrew study that was done
at the University of Jerusalem I believe
and essentially what they said was were
25 years behind in this research of
Mahlon
they should have started back in the 70s
when they started to see the decline in
these numbers and they'd see the decline
in actual sperm health and development
and they didn't do anything about it and
now they're going this is kind of a
crisis this seems like a like kind of a
dumb obvious one does that ought of guys
like take for granted this won't be a
problem I guess how do I even find out
that I would be infertile right now I
would say the first thing would be if
you and your spouse alike have been
trying to have kids and it's been over
12 months you know they say that over 12
months of consistent trying month after
month to have children and it's not
happening that's considered infertility
that's where we step in and we go okay I
gotta be
I gotta be manly about this and I gotta
I gotta step my game up and I've got to
think about possibly is is this a
malefactor thing could I be a
contributing factor to our infertility
and then you go into a clinic and you
get tested and get a sperm test done and
from there you know try to figure out if
there's a diagnosis or there's a reason
sometimes infertility is actually
undiagnosed infertility and there's not
a specific reason for it you could have
great fast strong swimmers and a ton of
them and she could have no signs of
let's say endometriosis or PCOS and you
just can't get pregnant and at that
point it's just trial and error I've had
you know like unprotected sex but I've
never gotten anyone pregnant so I was
always just like oh you know just good
just in the clear but I've never thought
like oh I could just not be able to get
someone pregnant sure so I when you
found out how did that affect you
mentally I think for a while it was this
like gut punch right to my manhood you
know it was like it was like well you're
supposed to be macho and and just strong
and
and I wasn't that like I felt wheat
right but for some reason I thought like
my sperm count made my identity mm-hmm
less you know we're talking about like
health and eating healthy I year I lost
like 50 pounds
crusher yeah man yeah I did a really
good job do you feel better I feel way
better
you know like healthier while we talk
about like you know the hell you know
what eating healthy and all that stuff
does genetics is it genetic is it get
passed down is that because you get
again you don't know I think is that's
something that it was like an indicator
or not kind of going back to it I think
there needs to be a lot of attention in
the medical field so that we can figure
this problem out because I know that
there are factors that contribute to
having a healthier reproductive system
for a male right it's getting the fat
off of your body which creates and that
heat is killing the whole system that's
creating sperm yep
and so the hotter your body runs the
less sperm you're likely to have so
that's why you see in overweight
populations there's we usually more
infertility problems and diagnoses for
male and female right because they're
carrying so much more than like - and
this is I don't know this but like I
would assume like you know if you are
going down the road of like trying the
different like treatments in the IVF
that would probably get relatively
expensive yep and so I guess I'm curious
like yeah in the country right now is
that something that's frequently covered
much by insurance or is it like really
kind of hit or miss and I would say for
the majority of infertility treatments
most insurances don't cover you're gonna
find with big corporations that they do
have some IVF extensions or there's like
a bucket within the company that they'll
be able to say hey we can help you with
X amount of IVF treatments but it's
insurances alone that it's really
difficult procreating and being able to
have kids is such a big thing okay do
you ever feel like you not being able to
do it she would leave you know what I
did think of that that was that's like
when I think about being a that's like
my biggest fears
someone being like oh you can't give me
a child why would I still be there were
moments and there were days for that I
would look at Alex I'd go if I can't
give this dream to you like I let here's
your way out
and she never took it and I am so
grateful that she didn't good it's
amazing because we're not in this
marriage for sex right we're not in this
marriage for babies we're in this
marriage to be unified as one and if if
it works that we get to have kids
biologically that's awesome applause but
guess what there's other ways to have
kids yeah for us adoption was an avenue
for us to have kids yeah
foster care is an avenue for people to
have children obviously great to meet
you thank you for just still being so
strong and I'll thank you and open for
me is really big to see man be open
about this with other man so this is
yeah beautiful beautiful well I'd say
for you man thank you for allowing me to
be a part visual vulnerability is the
biggest sign of strength I think what
this generation needs to see it because
we've got to get from behind the mask
and get in front of to show people who
we really are
[Music]
you